mais voilà bonjour vous êtes en direct
d'avignon où se trouve l'un des convois
justement alors des dizaines de
véhicules ont déjà pris la route quel
est l'enjeu de ce voyage pour les
manifestants
manifestement effectivement tout est
marqué dans le convoi des libertés les
gens ici veulent absolument montrer leur
désarroi et leur opposition fortin ce
qu'ils appellent une perte de liberté
suite au pass d'accidents liés aux
différentes déclarations mais plus
largement aussi plus largement sur une
faillite démocratique est en train de
s'assurer le pays depuis depuis
plusieurs mois et même depuis la crise
et gilet jaune est ici c'est très très
très claire les gens sont déterminés à
aller en ile-de-france pour être très
précis ça ne pense pas forcément sur
paris et puis certains certains m'ont
dit que si le mouvement continue et il
irait bien entendu jusqu'à bruxelles
voilà les premières informations temps
ici à avignon ce matin où le convoi l'un
d'eux vient de partir il ya quelques
minutes voilà à la mairie de bruxelles
d'ailleurs qu'il ya à l'instant
d'interdire à l'entrée du convoi de la
liberté
on l'a évoqué également dans ce journal
ce convoi s'inspire du canada cela
ferait presque quinze jours que les rues
d'ottawa sont bloqués par environ à 400
camions peut-on s'attendre à une
affluence similaire en ile-de-france
alors ici pour être très clair lors il
ya quelque chose qui est intéressant
c'est un coup de camions faut être très
clair il ya très peu de camions mais ce
qui est intéressant il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de voitures et deviennent dit
guy duel beaucoup de campings car
aujourd'hui comme je le disais je suis
pas sûr qu'il ya un pouvoir et non de
blocage je suis même pas sûr que ce soit
la volonté des porte parole puisque ça
va pas forcément l'organe à terme il ya
des porte-parole je pense que ce qu'on
voit se dirigent gentiment vers l'île de
france manifestement nous n'aurons pas
une cire sur la canadienne ou à la
québécoise c'est le cas aussi au québec
dans la ville de québec parce qu'il n'ya
pas de kamenar vous le savez les
camionneurs au canada sont propriétaires
de leurs camions ici ce n'est pas le cas
mais il va y avoir bien entendu des
rassemblements et on va voir tout au
long de la journée comment ça va se
passer ici parce qu'il ya eu des
centaines de voitures et si avignon
c'est un gros rassemblement même les
gens qui étaient sur place étaient
surpris de l'affluence beaucoup de
voitures sont parties et le monde qui
est là est très diverses et variées très
diverses et variées vous avez des
retraités vous avez des jeunes cadres
vous avez des familles si vous avez
beaucoup de gens dans une bonne humeur
c'était très festif la solidarité ça
c'est ce que je retiens c'est la
solidarité qu'on avait vu au début dé
gilet jaune rappelez vous avec les gens
qui allaient apporter des victuailles et
si j'ai vu des camions en grand camions
mais plein de plein de plein de
victuailles donc il ya vraiment cette
fraternité je crois que c'est le maître
mot ici de ces rassemblements c'est la
fraternité et la bonne ambiance mais
surtout très déterminés pour montrer la
contestation et certains me disaient
porte parole c'est un combo la liberté
nous voulons montrer que nous sommes
libres c'est un convoi de la libération
voilà les mots ici que j'ai entendu ce
matin en discutant avec les uns et les
autres alors on l'a déjà mentionné à la
préfecture de police de paris a donc
annoncé ce matin de l'interdiction a
pour ce convoi d'entrer dans la capitale
peut-on considérer voilà cette
interdiction comme une réponse du
gouvernement vis-à-vis de cette
initiative
bien sûr quand vous avez un communiqué
de presse qui paraît comme sakineh qui
émergent qui bourgeonnent ce matin en
disant que le convoi est interdit de
rentrer dans la capitale vous avez bien
noté que la capitale pas l'ile-de-france
effectivement le dédain du jura darmanin
finalement on voit que c'est un signal
du pouvoir à une fermeté à une fermeté
absolue de ne pas voir tellement de ne
pas avoir une situation situation
comment what about québec et on voit
bien que gouvernement maintenant
commence à se poser sur la seconde
question parce que je peux vous assurer
que les gens ici sont pacifique ou faut
le rappeler mais extrêmement déterminé à
aller l'ile-de-france et puis pour
certains bruxelles de oui la réponse du
gouvernement avec ce communiqué de la
préfecture de police de paris très
fermement va essayer de murs et de muret
c'est un mot c'est une image bien en
plus une parabole de murer l'accès au
périphérique parisien parce que c'est ça
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est le
périphérique parisien mais je crois que
les organisateurs et les gens qui par
titre qu'on appelle des convoyeurs ne
sont pas disposés à istres paris ils
vont rester dans la périphérie en ile de
france bien entendu mais je pense que
les barrages seront seront assez
conséquent concrètement nicolas vous
venez de vous
transmettre ou de servir un petit peu
cette détermination que vous sentez sur
le terrain de la part des manifestants
on sait aussi que l'exécutif s'inquiète
ça lui rappelle évidemment des mauvais
souvenirs avec la crise des gilet jaune
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un bras
de fer similaire entre les manifestants
qui sont autour de vous et le
gouvernement alors ça on va le voir et
effectivement c'est à craindre pour le
gouvernement bien entendu ça ferait
quand même un peu désordre pas c'est moi
l'expression qu'on ait une espèce de
crise et gilet jaune avec des gens plus
divers et encore et variées d'ailleurs
une observation qui me semblait très
intéressante je regardais hier soir
c'était un mur rue mais nous avons ici
des voitures des voitures pas de lui
mais des voitures haut de gamme donc ça
veut bien dire qu'ici dans les
manifestants vous avez une composition
sociale qui est très divers et variés et
le gouvernement a tout intérêt à
craindre finalement à moins de deux mois
la présidentielle comme moment ces tirs
comme ça alors se durcissent le
durcissement passera bien sûr par le
nombre il ne passera que par le nombre
mais le gouvernement a beaucoup à perdre
et dernière analyse aussi la question
qui se pose aussi que le gouvernement
devrait se poser la classe politique
devrait se poser c'est pourquoi ces gens
ont moins de deux mois la présidentielle
font un convoi de la liberté aussi
massif qui part de plusieurs foyers en
france on pourrait penser que les gens
vont voir tintin présidentielle
finalement pour voter selon leur bon gré
et attendre finalement un changement de
deux présidents et deux gouvernements et
les gens ici je vous le dis c'est une
faillite démocratique des gens ne
croient plus du tout à la classe
politique dont ils ont envie vraiment de
se faire entendre mais une nouvelle fois
c'est très pacifique c'est très très bon
enfant et beaucoup de solidarité moi
c'est ce qui me frappe c'est vraiment la
solidarité merci beaucoup nicolas vidal
notre éditorialiste politique en direct
d'avignon d'un convoi de la liberté